it wasn't just a show of support for
Israel's prime minister it was in effect
a call to Arms French president Emanuel
macron suggested taking joint
International action against
Hamas this is why France is ready for
the International Coalition against isil
within the framework of which we are
engaged for our operation in Iraq in
Syria in rala he reiterated his call to
treat Hamas like isil but in all his
statement was more sympathy than action
with no plans for a ceasefire or
humanitarian Corridor two immediate
demands of the
Palestinians I want to express my
condolences to all the victims of the
Spiral of the violence Unleashed by
Hamas to the families of the wounded and
those who lost their loved ones in Gazza
our hearts are with
them during the meeting protesters took
to the streets angry that abas would
even meet with the French leader Emanuel
MCR is just just the latest and a long
line of Western leaders to visit Israel
but he's only the second leader to come
and visit uh president mm abas here in
ramala Now France has publicly backed
Israel and most observers here say
there's not a huge amount he can do for
the
Palestinians Israel meanwhile continues
its near nightly raids in the occupied
West Bank Imran Khan Al
R make sure to subscribe to our channel
to get the latest news from
zero